On August 6th and 9th this year,...
...I visited Hiroshima and Nagasaki,...
...and spoke in person with atomic bomb survivors...
...and their second- and third-generation descendants.
I could not help feeling choked with emotion...
...at the fact that just two atomic bombs claimed more than 200 thousand lives...
...and seeing people who still suffer from the aftereffects of radiation over 60 years after the bombings.
I would like to encourage all leaders of the world to visit Hiroshima and Nagasaki...
...and absorb with their own eyes and ears the cruelty of nuclear weapons.
As a matter of historical fact,...
...Japan chose not to possess nuclear weapons even after achieving its postwar reconstruction.
In 1970, Japan signed the NPT and ratified it six years later.
In 1996, Japan signed the CTBT and ratified it a year later.